[Musik]
überall müll räumt ihn keiner weg
zerfällt er zum mikro plastik verseucht
schleichend unsere böden
ich denke dass es eines der größten
probleme was wir überhaupt haben immer
wieder landen plastikverpackungen auch
im biomüll werden zerkleinert und zu
kompost oder dünger verarbeitet
so gelangen kleinste teilchen auf die
äcker und in unsere gärten forscher
finden inzwischen hunderttausende
partikel auf jedem hektar egal in
welchem boden wir nach micro plastik
suchen gewähren micro plastik finden
umweltschützer schlagen alarm
über jahre wurde das problem ignoriert
dagmar stross vom naturschutzbund
deutschland und christian dittmann
schauen sich um auf einem beliebigen
acker in schleswig holstein
überall liegt plastik müll herum
achtlos weggeworfen am wegesrand aber
auch auf dem feld
wenn man nicht darauf achtet dann sieht
man es gar nicht mehr wildes schon so
normal geworden dass es gar nicht mehr
gesehen wird wenn der mühe ist jedes mal
wenn der flug drüber geht wird das noch
mal ein stück kleiner
und er ist scheint die sonne drauf also
das löst ja auch den prozess aus dass es
dann sich verhärtet und dann anfängt zu
bröseln ja und am ende wird unter gefügt
und das ist verschwendet micro plastik
verschwindet ja nie es wird dann
vielleicht irgendwann noch plastik aber
das macht es ja eher noch gefährlicher
niemand sammelt es auf nach und nach
bringt es in die böden ein
hier ist ein stück plastik was eben
schon dass das licht schon länger und
das ist schon so papierart ich
irgendwann ist es micro plastik was
macht das zeug im boden mit den ganzen
weichmachern antioxidationsmittel und so
weiter die dann am boden landen und am
ende welche auswirkung hat es auf die
pflanzen und dann letztlich auf den
menschlichen organismus
genau mit diesen fragen beschäftigen
sich wissenschaftler an der universität
in bayreuth in ihrem fokus kompost die
aus biomüll gewonnen wird so wie dieser
schon auf den ersten blick sind in der
bodenprobe kunststoffteile zu erkennen
aufwändig lösen die forscher stücke
heraus auch kleinstes micro plastik
unter 5 mm größe
[Musik]
dieser kompost ist regelrecht verseucht
neue studien warnen dass in unseren
böden 20 mal mehr plastik schlummert als
in den weltmeeren die forscher in
bayreuth haben tatsächlich in allen
stichproben jede menge davon gefunden
hochgerechnet mehr als 150.000 micro
plastikteilchen pro hektar untersuchte
ackerfläche
egal ob ich in ihrem garten nach micro
plastik suche oder jetzt auf der wiese
vor der universität oder auf
irgendwelchen äckern wir werden
micro plastik finden der micro plastik
natürlich über unterschiedlichste
eintrags pfade auch auf äcker
eingetragen wird über die luft die
position natürlich die kunststoffe die
in der landwirtschaft verwendet werden
aber natürlich auch über düngemittel im
labor müssen die bodenproben aufwendig
aufgearbeitet werden die ergebnisse sind
alarmierend
in einer ersten studie enthielt jede
tonne kompost aus der haushalts
müllabfuhr bis zu 440.000 micro plastik
partikel
sorgen machen den forschern vor allem
die kleinste teilchen die für das
menschliche auge nicht mehr sichtbar
sind
wir sortieren quasi alle partikel die
potenziell kunststoff sein können also
die aufgrund der optischen eigenschaften
so ausschauen aus den proben raus bis zu
einer größe von einem millimeter runter
und die werden dann foto dokumentiert
und im nachgang dann wenn sie es so wie
der hier ein bisschen dreckig sind auch
gereinigt sie von oben ohne kunststoff
nein also wir hatten auch wenn es dann
ganz wenig nur war aber wir haben
eigentlich in jeder probe was gefunden
über 60 prozent der fundstücke sind
polyethylen aus lebensmittelverpackungen
zu dem styropor und pc
das fraunhofer institut hat errechnet
woher das ganze plastik in der umwelt
kommt
platz eins abrieb von fahrzeugreifen
verluste bei der abfallentsorgung darin
auch verpackungen und plastik im kompost
straßenbelag abrieb vom asphalt bei der
produktion des plastiks und beim
transport kunstrasenplätze hier vor
allem das eingestreute granulat
[Musik]
doch wie kommt das ganze plastik auf den
acker com postierter biomüll ist ein
begehrter bodenverbesserer jeden tag
produzieren die kommunalen betriebe
große mengen davon
sie sind froh wenn die landwirte den
kompost abwählen
doch in dem bio dünger ist fast immer
plastik enthalten
auch nach diesem ausbringen sind mit
bloßem auge auf jedem quadratmeter
kunststoffteile zu sehen
der landwirt freiherr von bikes hat
deshalb jahrelang auf kompost verzichtet
nun probiert es mal wieder auf seinen
feldern die ausbringung hat hier sehr
gut funktioniert das heißt das streu
bild so nennen wir das ist sehr
gleichmäßig und nun sucht man irgendwo
eine ob man von diesen störstoffen etwas
findet und hier das soll nicht sein wir
wollen keine beimischung kein plastik
kein irgendwas auf dem acker hahn
doch solches plastik im kompost ist in
geringen mengen erlaubt der gesetzgeber
kapituliert offenbar vor der plastik
flut in unseren haushalten und die
bauern die auf diesen dünger angewiesen
sind müssen es ausbaden meint freiherr
von bikes das gesamte bild der
gesellschaft muss auf diesen fokus sein
und nicht einzeln auf den landwirt
abgeladen werden der mit seinem acker
sich dann am ende dieser kette nicht
mehr wirklich erwehren kann außer
verweigert die stoffe in unserer
gesellschaft ist plastik allgegenwärtig
4,5 millionen tonnen verpackungen wurden
in deutschland im letzten jahr
produziert beutel folien becher
einwegflaschen
immer mehr obwohl seit jahren über das
müllproblem geredet wird
die deutsche kunststoffindustrie hatte
2018 ein rekordjahr mit 64 milliarden
euro umsatz ein ungebrochener trend
[Musik]
immer mehr von diesem plastik kommt auch
hier an
bei der firma bio tann in fulda aus müll
entsteht hier gas für 1200 haushalte in
der region vor allem aus
lebensmittelabfällen wie diesen
supermärkte liefern jeden tag mehrere
lkw-ladungen mit unverkaufter waren
27.000 tonnen jedes jahr vieles davon
noch originalverpackt
trotzdem gilt so eine fuhre als biomüll
es ist aufwendig und teuer das plastik
von den lebensmitteln zu trennen
denn für die gasproduktion wird
eigentlich nur die biomasse benötigt
in dieser hammermühle wird alles
zerquetscht stücke größer als 1,5 cm
werden herausgesägt die großen
plastikteile gehen in die
müllverbrennung die kleineren mit in die
vergärung wir tun hier auf der anlage
alles damit wir so viel wie möglich
kunststoff herausbekommen aber zu 100
bekommen wir das nicht in dem der rest
dürfen maximal 0,1 und stoffreste
zurückbleiben dass die entsprechende
gesetzliche regelung wir werden
kontinuierlich überprüft und liegen
regelmäßig deutlich unter diesen
größenordnung in diesem tanks werden die
speisereste erhitzt so entsteht biogas
dass dann weitere zu methan verarbeitet
wird
übrig bleiben die sogenannten flüssigen
gärrest sie enthalten micro plastik auch
wenn bio kann viel dafür tut möglichst
viel herauszufiltern dieser gärreste
gehen dann wie gülle als dünger aufs
feld kommen dann bei 0 5 mm aus
kunststoff resten so dass diese mit dem
bloßen auge kaum zu erkennen sind
das heißt also wir erkennen auf den
feldern keine plastik schnipsel die
irgendwo in der sonne schimmern
was in fulda funktioniert ging in
schleswig-holstein gründlich schief im
frühjahr 2018 machte ein umweltskandal
schlagzeilen viele tonnen plastik wurden
aus der schleier ans ufer gespült
verseuchten schilf streifen und
schutzgebiete verursacher diese
kläranlage in ihr werden ebenfalls
lebensmittelreste vergoren störstoffe
und kunststoffe herausgesägt eigentlich
doch dann war die technik offenbar
überfordert wir stellten jetzt fest dass
wir eben in letzter zeit auch
kunststoffreste mit angeliefert bekommen
haben
insbesondere im januar diesen jahres war
die fracht sowie wir ermitteln konnten
sehr hoch und dies führte wahrscheinlich
eben dann zu einem auftrag weil hier die
für sandfilter dieser fragte an
kunststoffen in fremd bestandteile nicht
mehr auffangen konnte ein jahr später
noch haben sich die ufer der schleier
nicht vom plastik erholt da cruz und
christian dittmann finden an den ufern
noch immer etwas
inzwischen auch schon in den boden
eingesunken
im ersten moment war es natürlich
eigentlich schockierend weil man sich ja
vorstellen muss dass wir in die schlei
die plastik brösel schon fertig
geschreddert reinschmeißen so dass sie
gleich die perfekte größe haben um
maximal umwelt schädlich zu sein
außerhalb der brutzeit sammelt christian
dittmann seegras am ufer produziert
daraus kopfkissen für touristen bei
seinen gängen durchs schilf findet ihr
immer mehr müll
ich kann jetzt hier ein bisschen sauber
machen und etwas für mein gewissen tun
und tatsächlich hier auch gerade war
punktuell so ein bisschen helfen dass
das nicht alles in die natur geht aber
am ende wenn man ganz ehrlich ist weiß
man ganz genau dass man nicht wirklich
helfen kann
denn der müll zerbröselte im lauf der
zeit verschwindet in der erde verweht
oder wächst zwischen den pflanzen ein
letztlich ist landet im schilf ist
landet am ende auch wieder auf
irgendwelchen ecken irgendwelchen böden
und beeinflusst in irgendeiner weise an
irgendeiner stelle ein ökosystem
doch gelangt das mikro plastik auch in
den körper des menschen
mit dieser frage haben sich forscher der
medizinischen universität wien
beschäftigt den anstoß gab der
gastroenterologe philipp schwabl ihm
waren ungewöhnliche darmentzündungen bei
patienten aufgefallen
zusammen mit bettina wittmann vom
österreichischen umweltbundesamt
untersuchte ihr stuhlproben von acht
zufällig ausgewählten menschen aus aller
welt
das ergebnis alle enthielten micro
plastik wir haben im mittel circa 20
teilchen plastik pro zehn gramm stuhl
gefunden
das überraschende war dass wir hier
einerseits die bekannten verpacktes
kunststoffe gefunden haben zu einem sehr
großen teil also polypropylen und auch
pc dass man von trinkflaschen kennt aber
auch bis zu sieben unterschiedliche
weitere kunststoffe wie das mikro
plastik in den körper gelangt dazu gibt
es erste hinweise
es wurde in getränken bier und
mineralwasser aber auch in
nahrungsmitteln wie fisch nachgewiesen
eine ursache könnte auch der abrieb von
flaschen deckeln und verpackungen seien
oder wie hier fasern aus textilien
der größte teil jetzt sicherlich
ausgeschieden
in tierstudien hat man gesehen dass
kleinste micro plastikteilchen zu einem
kleinen grab auch aufgenommen werden
können
diese hat man dann zb in blut oder auch
in der leber oder lymphknoten gefunden
das heißt an der stelle wo der eintritt
stattfindet kann es zu einer der
immunreaktion kommen zu einer
entzündungsreaktion kleine verletzungen
in den organen könnten die folge sein
auch weichmacher und andere stoffe die
sich herauslösen gelangen in den körper
so die vermutung auf platz 1 der quellen
für micro plastik im boden steht der
reifen abbringen
jedes jahr werden in deutschland über 50
millionen neue reifen verkauft in ihnen
steckt ein kunststoff gemisch aus
synthetischem kautschuk und industrie
rung der abrieb ist technisch notwendig
damit der reifen auf der straße haftet
von reifen der neu hatte 8 mm wird
runtergefahren bis 1,6 mm und das halt
dazwischen bleibt nachher auf der straße
liegen beziehungsweise geht in die
umwelt mehr als 100.000 tonnen
reifenabrieb entstehen jedes jahr in
deutschland und landen in der umwelt das
haben ralf bertling und boris tresen vom
fraunhofer institut in oberhausen
berechnet derzeit untersuchen sie wie
groß die reifen partikel in der umwelt
sind und wohin sie sich verbreiten
also hier wenn die straße befahren wird
dann natürlich da wo die fahrzeuge
fahren also man sieht jetzt keine spur
wegen der witterung bei niederschlägen
ist es dann aber so dass die straße halt
zum gefälle hin entwässert dh der
reifenabrieb fließt mit dem regen
richtung juni also strömt im grunde auch
hier rein und wenn du erste probe nehmen
wollen dann will man das wahrscheinlich
hier tun an dieser stelle in der stadt
filtern kläranlagen einiges heraus was
in die gullys gelangt aber auf den
randstreifen und in den straßengräben
dringt das mikro plastik in den boden
ein
wie weit es sich verbreitet und durch
die luft fliegt wollen die forscher
jetzt herausfinden was wir natürlich war
was unter gekratzt natürlich auch wissen
müssen ist der reifenabrieb
beispielsweise mit der straße verbunden
weil man spricht heute nicht mehr vor
den reifenabrieb sondern von trw pt1
what you're partikels dhm bundesmann
sagt das impliziert dass er reifenabrieb
mit dem start mit der straße auch eine
verbindung eingegangen ist der
reifenabrieb gilt auch als erzeuger von
gefährlichem feinstaub
die forschung zum mikro plastik generell
und beim reifenabrieb steckt noch in den
kinderschuhen
das fraunhofer-institut in oberhausen
beschäftigt sich erst seit 2008 10 dank
hauptproblem ist die kleinen partikel
zunächst vom asphalt oder aus
bodenproben zu isolieren
bevor sie vermessen und gezählt werden
können mit diesen daten wollen sie
karten über die belastung in deutschland
erstellen
unklar ist ob die partikel von pflanzen
aufgenommen werden
vielleicht ist der boden jetzt gerade
durch das thema reifenabrieb so ein
bisschen auf die agenda gekommen weil
der reifenabrieb der von der straße
abgespielt wird der landtag erst mal im
boden der reifen besteht natürlich nicht
zu hundert prozent aus kunststoffen das
ist ein viel stoffgemisch da ist
kautschuk trennen da ist robusteren da
sind schwermetalle drin da sind metalle
drin
ein weiteres problem für unsere böden
sportplätze die sind immer öfter mit
kunstrasen bewegt mehr als 7000 solcher
kunstrasenplätze gibt es derzeit in
deutschland tendenz steigend weniger der
abrieb der kunststoff halme ist ein
problem sondern vielmehr die kleinen
granulat kügelchen die lange aus
giftigen reifen resten recycelt wurden
sie sind auf jedem zweiten
kunstrasenplatz vorhanden und soll den
platz besser bespielbar machen von der
partikel größer es ist gerade fünf
millimeter also dementsprechend ist also
eine plastik und ich habe jetzt einfach
mal eingegriffen und eine kleine probe
auf die hand gelegt das ist eine ganze
menge platz drin und man kann sich
vorstellen wenn ich jetzt mal den
schulhof nehmen da sieht man auch sehr
schön dass ich was am start davon
gelangt nach jedem training ein wenig in
die umwelt und immer neues granulat muss
nachgefüllt werden
bei der anlage von so einem platz wenn
man jetzt mal von dem eigentlichen
kunstrasen absieht werden etwa je
nachdem wie groß der platz ist 40 bis
100 tonnen gummi granulat aufgebracht
und es wird etwa geschätzt dass davon
pro jahr so um die fünf prozent
ausgetragen werden und dann eben auch
jährlich ersetzt werden müssen
auch in oberhausen sind gerade mehrere
kunstrasenplätze fertiggestellt worden
oder noch im bau wie dieser alle werden
mit gummigranulat versehen
die forscher meinen dass es auch
alternativen gibt die genauso gut
bespielbar wären stärker die kritik
geäußert wird desto mehr werden auch
hersteller und betreiber von solchen
plätzen dazu übergehen anstatt
gummigranulat quark sahne zu verwenden
doch noch gelangen jedes jahr etwa 8000
tonnen gummi granulat in unserer umwelt
verschwinden auch in den böden
ein weiteres problem die entsorgung der
riesigen kunstrasenflächen wenn sie nach
etwa 20 jahren ausgedient haben
viele landen bislang in der
müllverbrennung keine lösung meinen die
betreiber dieser firma bei bonn
sie setzen sich für eine
weiterverwertung der plastikrasen ein
zum beispiel für reitsport plätze doch
sie kaufen nur die großen
kunststoffbahnen an das granulat wird
vorher abgesaugt und entsorgt
vertriebsleiter daniel bahr hält die
kleinen körnchen für umwelt schädlich
[Musik]
der regel sind das meistens immer
granulate die aus alten autoreifen
geschreddert werden sodass dieses
granulat danach auf diesem jahr platz
mit eingearbeitet werden kann und das
granulat so gesehen immer für die
weichheit eines platzes verantwortlich
beispielsweise im fußballbereich einfach
den ball ein bisschen weicher abholt und
ein bisschen weicher springt als wenn
man jetzt zum beispiel sand verwenden
würde
es gibt halt granulate sie haben eine
zertifikation die können recycelt werden
aber leider gibt es halt auch granulate
die nicht mehr recycelt werden können
und so was wird dann in der regel
verbrannt und das ist halt nicht ganz
förderlich
dennoch hielt der buhmann viele
sportvereine setzen auf kunstrasen mit
granulat statt auf naturrasen oder
ascheplätze trotz aller umweltrisiken zu
viel plastik auch im biomüll im
westfälischen soest kämpfen die
entsorgungsbetriebe dagegen an
der biomüll wird hier zu kompost
verarbeitet so wie es das abfall
kreislauf gesetz vorsieht
trotz image kampagnen und
aufklärungsarbeit viele verbraucher
schmeißen noch immer plastik in die
biotonne
ganze verpackungen genauso wie beutel
aus kunststoff statt aus papier
natürlich typisch überlagerte kartoffeln
die schmeißt waren komplett mit dem
letzter rein das ist auch nicht das so
wie wir es uns wünschen es entscheidend
ist städte und gemeinden der bürger dazu
bekommen die qualität verbessern nur da
ist die große stellschraube der input
ist entscheidend für unseren prozess mit
prozess ist die kompostierung des
biomülls gemeint dazu wird hier alles an
groben fremdstoffen aussortiert größere
plastikteile wandern in die
müllverbrennung
wir sortieren extrem viel aus aber
kleiner teil kann man nicht vermeiden
dass der durchrutscht und dann letztlich
in kompost landet vier monate lang wird
der biomüll hier auf haufen geschüttet
und mehrmals gewendet
das plastik in dem bio dünger nichts zu
suchen hat ist für geschäftsführer
jürgen schreiber nachvollziehbar
sie bekommt natürlich von dem kunden dem
landwirt den gartenbauer da ist unser
anspruch auf und auch sein anspruch
bestes material zu bekommen
er möchte einen sauren humus als
bodenverbesserer auf seinen feldern auf
seinem boden der muss ja auch kommt und
werden wir langfristig nachhaltig
abfallwirtschaft und kreislaufwirtschaft
betreiben wollen gerade im bereich der
bio abfälle müssen wir an der qualität
immer noch besser werden was also kann
man tun um plastik auf äckern und in
gärten in zukunft zu reduzieren
juve trifft sich mit dem geschäftsführer
eines dachverbandes der kompost
hersteller
nach viel kritik haben sie das problem
micro plastik in den böden aufgegriffen
und arbeiten an verbesserungen
inzwischen gibt es erste erfolge die
gesetzlichen grenzwerte halten sie
jedoch für unzureichend
der gesetzgeber gibt ja vor als
düngemittelverordnung 0,1 prozent in der
trockenmasse wenn man das umrechnet
würde das hakt etwas käme man in etwa
auf diese größenordnung von 100 knapp
170 von 3 cm pro liter kompost das
natürlich unhaltbar was schreibe damit
meint mit so viel plastik im kompost
sind die kunden nicht zufrieden
deshalb haben die anlagenbetreiber sich
freiwillig verpflichtet die erlaubten
werte deutlich zu unterschreiten
doch dazu sind sie darauf angewiesen
dass die verbraucher ihren müll
ordentlich trennen
weil diejenigen die bioabfälle behandeln
in der regel wenig einfluss haben auf
die qualitäten dieser angeliefert
bekommen und das ist die eigentliche
krux die wir auch bei der wir denken
dass dort weitere maßnahmen einfach
erforderlich sind um zu weniger
fremdstoffe in dem input material zu
kommen
doch das geht offenbar nur mit druck der
landkreis soest will nicht länger
akzeptieren dass zu viel plastik in bio
müll landet wer nicht sauber trennt muss
seinen müll behalten
also ist alles unrat
das kommt alles nicht daran
aufkleber drauf annahme verweigert nur
wenn der besitzer neu sortiert wird sie
beim nächsten mal geleert oder gegen
extra gebühren als restmüll entsorgt
doch besonders in mehrfamilienhäusern
funktioniert die mülltrennung oft nicht
so lange es verbraucher gibt die jede
menge plastik kaufen und dann in den
biomüll schmeißen ist dem problem herr
zu werden
die wissenschaftler an der universität
in bayreuth haben wiederholt studien auf
äckern durchgeführt
dazu haben sie proben genommen sowohl
von der oberfläche als auch einige
zentimeter tief auffällig war dass die
böden auf denen bio müll aus der
privaten tonne als kompost aufgebracht
war sehr viele plastikteile enthielt vor
allem von typen beuteln und behältern
wie schnell sich die unterschiedlichen
kunststoff sorten in den einzelnen böden
zum mikro plastik zersetzen oder
vielleicht auch generell zersetzt werden
es bis dato noch nicht bekannt
es ist bekannt dass kunststoffe
natürlich über lügen in den boden
eingetragen werden kann aber auch
natürlich regenwürmer die diese kunst
abartig mit aufnehmen können diese
kunststoff partikel dann tiefer in die
erde mit eintragen was das für
auswirkungen hat
da steht man auch erst am anfang dabei
könnte es geschehen dass die
bodenbeschaffenheit verändert wird und
es damit natürlich auch dann
auswirkungen generell auf die pflanzen
haben könnte die auf diesem boden
wachsen
viele fragen sind noch offen und viele
probleme noch nicht gelöst
deshalb hat die universität bayreuth zu
beginn des jahres einen eigenen
forschungsbereich für micro plastik
eingerichtet
die umweltschützer in schleswig-holstein
fordern schnelle politische schritte um
eine deutliche reduzierung von
plastikverpackungen zu erreichen was bis
jetzt bereits in die umwelt gelangt ist
sei schon schlimm genug dass das ist
doch nicht durch die sonne kaputt das
ist doch irgendwie beim mähen wenn sie
sich die gräben mähen oder suchen sich
ist alles voll normaal sieht man das ja
nicht weil man seine augen auf seinen
blick auf was anderes konzentriert aber
wenn du ihnen wirklich mein held an der
straße und diesem paar quadratmeter an
guckst du echt krass erstaunt also ich
würd mal sagen jetzt hier anfangen zu
sammeln dann haben wir wahrscheinlich in
kürzester zeit 100 teile auf drei
quadratmetern eingesammelt immerhin eine
erste initiative gibt es die
umweltminister von schleswig-holstein
und baden-württemberg fordern dass
supermärkte lebensmittel nicht mehr
verpackt entsorgen dürfen
es hat sich herausgestellt dass mit
freiwilligkeit nicht viel zu erreichen
ist wir müssen jetzt wirklich nägel mit
köpfen machen vor allem die politik muss
nägel mit köpfen machen eigentlich kann
es nicht sein dass eu weit so viel
plastik auf den er kann landet
vermüllt und verseucht seit jahren wurde
das problem ignoriert nun sind unsere
böden ernsthaft in gefahr
[Musik]